haha the Joe Rogan experience he's not
the only reason why I've ever been in
any movies well I did some terrible
movies that nobody saw before but like
the movies that I did once I didn't need
to do anything anything anymore anymore
in terms of acting was his movies I did
two of his music I did a new key / and I
did here comes the boom and the only
reason why I did it was cuz I love Kevin
he's such a great zookeeper was fun - it
was so ridiculous I had to learn how to
dance it's like it took months and
months of my time was really interested
I saw that dance in all fairness some of
what you see is not actually me some of
it is me but there was this dude who was
a professional dancer who was like a
stand-in yeah who was amazing he was
amazing so the the stuff where it's
clearly me I definitely did a lot of the
stuff all the stuff with me and leslie
bibb where i hold her and all that stuff
that was me a hundred percent but this
is so much better than me where you
couldn't tell they stuck him in you know
and he was like built like me and he
would it was perfect it was like nobody
could tell because because he was really
good like when you see how hard it is to
actually dance you go my god like when
you see a real professional it's one of
the most dismissed things of people
oh we dismiss it like oh what a
frivolous pursuit and I knew how to
dance but if you can really dance it's
so impressive when someone has like full
control of their body that's what Tom
said to me because I'm a better dancer
than him dude I did [ __ ] Tom let me tell
you something that [ __ ] my
daughter's my daughter's my daughter's
saw Tom's video and they looked at in
there like wait Tom can dance I go you
didn't say that when you saw my video
and they go will you paid someone to
teach you how to dance I go so - [ __ ]
he you think he did that on his own they
go it looks like it I tried to do that
Irish dance for the release of the
special but you got appreciate the fact
that Tom did it in a Steven Seagal a
little carrot don't ever like if you I
swear to God if you watch the video of
me watch enough for the
first time it's a love letter it's a man
reading a love letter from his boyfriend
when Tom's he I said I he goes how do
you feel I said like probably I go made
me feel very honored that you did that
and he goes because I love you like so
like when he put that out I meant so
much because I go because I thought I
put out my dance video and everyone made
fun of it we watched it we giggled but
the fact that it inspired Tom to drop
eighty thousand whatever he spent eighty
five hundred thousand hundred ten
thousand it the fact that he made a
reply video made me so [ __ ] excited
when he went so deep he went
do you realize what he did he made me he
told me he goes i sat and did facial
recognition for him yeah we talked about
it oh he [ __ ] you hard bro bro you
have no idea the times I stay up in bed
going this home getting Tommy I swear to
God when the guy had the machine shirt
on we sell those it we sell those now
and they're [ __ ] going crazy they're
all at my show just milk sheen
[Applause]